[Music]
joining a Jennifer Lawrence comedy for
viewing options this week is a new Wes
Anderson film a mysterious Marvel
miniseries the return of a show that is
bound to make you hungry yet again and a
lovely pick for pride month we're
bringing you all that and finding off a
scroll Invasion maybe on this week's
what to watch I'm an Uber driver and I
don't have a car
come on up
his parents said if I quote date their
son they'd give me a Buick Regal opening
in theaters is the comedy no hard
feelings along with the obvious presence
of the film's co-producer star Jennifer
Lawrence one reason to check this one
out is it's interesting and funny
premise which is Jayla plays an Uber
driver who is close to losing her
childhood home so she answers a
Craigslist ad from two parents who want
their introverted son played by Andrew
Barth Feldman to date and hook up with
someone before college and to build on
that is the second reason to see this
one it's based on an actual real life
Craigslist ad not mine shout out to all
my Craigslist freaks plus no hard
feelings was directed by Jean stop
nitsky who knows a thing or two about
comedy after working as a writer
director and co-executive producer over
four seasons of The Office the car
exploded
yeah
come get the girls I have to stay here
with Woodrow another chauffeur I'm the
grandfather where are you asteroid City
farm Route 6 Mile 75. also Crash Landing
into theaters is the new Wes Anderson
film asteroid City and well the first
reason to try and catch this one has
already been stated Wes Anderson he's
the guy behind certified fresh called
Classics and fan favorites like Rushmore
the Royal tannenbaums Moonrise Kingdom
and The Grand Budapest Hotel dang that's
impressive but if you want more reasons
how about a whole truckload of A-list
Stars making up for this film's ensemble
cast we're talking Jason schwartzman's
Scarlett Johansson Tom Hanks Jeffrey
Wright till the Swinton Brian Cranston
Edward Norton Adrian Brody Lev Schreiber
Steve Carell Willem Dafoe Margot Robbie
and Jeff Goldblum to name just a dozen
dang that's impressive and if you're
waiting for critic approval on this one
we are glad to tell you that asteroid
city is fresh on the Tomato Meter with
nearly 100 reviews and critics say that
those who respond to Anderson's
signature style will find this a return
to immaculately arranged form it's all
about the framing folks things have
gotten much worse
how you think I came back
people trading its way into Disney plus
is the new Marvel mini-series secret
Invasion this one is based on the Marvel
Comics storyline of the same name from
2008 which is our first reason for
tuning in and not only is Samuel L
Jackson's Nick Fury a main centerpiece
of the show he's joined by a handful of
other recurring MCU characters played by
Ben mendelsohn Kobe Smulders Martin
Freeman and Don Cheadle but that's not
all folks because this already fresh
miniseries on the Tomato Meter also
includes some fresh faces joining the
Marvel fun as well including Emilia
Clarke Olivia Coleman and Dermot
Mulroney this is going to be a
destination spot we drafted a quick term
sheet we need more money will you turn
that thing off please how should that
make a new insane
I don't mind it another filling option
for your streaming appetite is the
return of the hit series The Bear and by
hit series we're talking about season
one being a certified fresh 100 on the
Tomato Meter that's one zero zero
percent how do you improve on something
like that here's an idea bring an
emmy-winning genius into the fold as a
guest star they did and his name is Bob
Odenkirk who knows a thing or two about
hit TV shows so now take those two
little factoids and throw them on a
hoagie roll with this season two will
have two more episodes than season one
did moving from eight to ten you're
welcome well I didn't have anything to
do with it but you you know what I'm
saying who do you think it is
can I call you back
[Music]
dear blue I'm just like you
and finally our pride inspired pick this
week is the Romantic dramedy love Simon
just in time for pride month but a great
option any time of the year this film
was groundbreaking in 2018 as the first
mainstream Studio released teen rom-com
with a gay lead character this fresh
take on the coming of age story follows
17 year old Simon played by Nick
Robinson who is falling in love with an
anonymous classmate online and he has
yet to tell his family and friends that
he's gay love Simon also Stars Jennifer
Garner and Josh demell as amazing and
entertaining parental figures supporting
a great young cast that includes
Catherine Langford and Keenan Lonsdale
alongside Robinson and if you love this
movie there's also a spin-off series
called love Victor on Hulu
well there you have it five picks to
fill you up this week with what exactly
well that's up to you and now that is
starting to sound a little weird be sure
to let us and your fellow viewers know
in the comments what you did check out
whether it was on this list or not
remember to check out rottentomatoes.com
for the latest updates on scores and
reviews for everything mentioned as well
as the movie and TV World At Large
that's all for today fresh family until
next week stay fresh
foreign